Let's get ready for date night in, like,
20 minutes. I've already done my base and my eyebrows.
I'm just gonna do, like,
a really quick. I like a really light one,
because I wanna do a full,
bold red lip. We're going to a caviar bar tonight,
which I think leads, like,
dramatic,
elegant. So I'm just doing a really,
really light smoky eye. Like,
just a teeny little touch, um,
with this color in the crease,
and then this one just in the outer corner.
And I always do a little bit of this silk teddy just in this corner,
and then I'll do my wing.
I'm gonna go in with the tattoo liner and just do a little wing
and drag that out.
I usually connect the top and the bottom to make a little triangle,
and then fill it in and then just connect it to the inner corner.
Now for a red lip, I'm trying a new one.
I've been really liking the Pat Mcgrath red,
and this is actually gonna be Charlotte Tilbury Hollywood fixin.
Now,
I'm always on the hunt for a good red,
and this is a good red. I've always liked Charlotte Tilbury's lipsticks.
I know they're a little bit on the pricey side,
but they go on creamy, and they are just, like,
so hydrating and really pigmented,
and I really love them.
I'm gonna finish off with a little bit of highlight just up here on
the cheek bone. Um,
and this is benefit Watts Up.
I've used it to hell. I fucking love it.
It's really great. Um,
but that's the whole makeup look.
I'm gonna have to do a part two for getting dressed
because I don't want this to be,
like a seven minute long video.
Um, so go for part two for the outfit.